yeah i think i think we're going to see
alex smith
yeah and uh smith is going to do
everything he has to do to play
in that game it's win and in it's i
people have asked me why did the nfl
select washington philadelphia for prime
time because philadelphia's not playing
for anything and it is funny to
see some of the philadelphia beat
writers complain about having to stay up
past nine o'clock on sunday night to
cover a team that
it's irrelevant at this point but it's a
it's a a great six-hour window to
determine the nfc east because you've
got the elimination game first
between the cowboys and the giants the
winner is alive the loser is dead and
the winner goes and watches what
washington does and if washington wins
therein and if washington loses
the winner of the giants cowboys game is
in i love that six hour window
well yeah it's great well it's it's i
because i had some friends text me too
like why is that the game it's
it's because it's the only game that's
guaranteed to mean something
you know truly as far as the playoffs
and who gets in and gets out
you know if it wasn't washington
philadelphia
everything else could have been settled
by the time we got to sunday night
football we would have had no game to
to put on tv or at least no game with
meaning so
yeah we want meaning in prime time spots
there i don't want to watch a
a 8 15 you know sunday night scrimmage
between two football teams i definitely
don't i i think there is
think about it think about it the way
they've got it set up they've got all
those impactful games clustered at 4 25
p.m eastern
and then if the game that starts at 8 15
means nothing by the time
all the other games are resolved who's
going to watch it
who's going to care we've just seen all
of these games and have all these
tentacles and connections and
this game affects this game the other
talking in indianapolis about not
putting up the score of the titans
texans game because they don't want the
players you know
looking up the scoreboard to see what
they need to do against the jaguars and
and or whether or not it even matters to
beat the jaguars if they you know all of
those things
it's fun and so all that ends and
there's a game that doesn't mean
anything
who cares about that this is a game that
is guaranteed to mean
something esp and it and it's a great
combination
it makes the cowboys giants game even
better because
that game has to go to its conclusion
before we know who's still alive
and then boom you hand the baton to
washington and philly and if washington
wins they're in and if they lose
whoever won that early game i love it i
do too now it's still
it's still the worst division in
football but they're still hosting a
playoff game
and we've seen teams sub 500
hosting playoff games wild card weekend
and winning the seahawks did it to the
saints
and the panthers ron rivera's panthers
did it
to the cardinals it didn't help the
cardinals that they had ryan
lindley playing quarterback instead of
carson palmer right but the
but we've seen sub 500 teams win in the
postseason so you know
throw out the records at this point what
matters at this point is
washington wins the division if they win
sunday night if they lose the winner of
the cowboys giants game is in i love it
yeah no it's crazy i mean well and it's
you know there's
there's almost a part of me that wants
to see the giants in and be like well we
got a six and ten football team
hosting a playoff game there's a part of
me that hosting that hosting
tom brady tom brady i know whoever wins
is going to get to host tom brady and
the tampa bay buccaneers that's your
consolation prize i don't think that's
good for washington
i don't think they match up well but
either way i'm like i'm with you on
sunday night
you know washington philadelphia we
still got the jalen hurts thing
jalen hurts played well again last week
yeah he threw an interception down in
the red zone
okay they were down 13 points he had to
make something happen it was a third
down i believe it might have even been a
fourth down i can't remember exactly
i've watched so much damn football
but did a lot of good things i'm fine
i'm excited to watch him one more time
and then this washington defense you
know and of course with alex smith
they play the right way as a total team
he takes care of the ball he takes care
of the ball
he's charlie check down he's charlie
check down you want to pull your hair
out watching him going please throw the
ball more than seven
feet please but then he waits until he
feels like
okay now it's time let me start let me
start just pushing the envelope a little
bit
just like you did with the steelers
football game and all of a sudden you
look up and you go
damn he was so boring and average all
game and here he is they're gonna win
the game
and he made enough throws at the in the
last quarter here to help them get over
the hump to win it
and i'm excited to see if alex smith can
do that him and ron rivera this you know
comeback story they've had is pretty
special
bad news for washington at a [ __ ]
boot he missed the week 16
game he's been great this year for
washington so they're going to have to
get some offensive productions
that's the defense though that's been
driving the bus and you're right look
it's not like the eagles are going to
lay down it's a prime time game
doug peterson is justifiably starting to
wonder about his future in philadelphia
jalen hurts trying to
develop him for next year if nothing
else this is a pre-season game
for next year this is an opportunity for
hertz
to do something that allows him to feel
better about
his potential as a starter and everyone
else to feel better about his potential
as a starter for next year so
i look i i i understand that like ram's
cardinal well
not that rams cardinals is going to be a
sexier game if the starting quarterbacks
aren't playing but
this one this one has the potential to
be
very fascinating and the prospect of the
giants
hosting tom brady and what the giants
have done to brady over the course of
his career and they had that monday
night game that went down to the wire
and the joe judge angle without all of
his time with the patriots
yeah yeah that i
look sorry cowboys fans sorry washington
fans and i really
do think that washington winning the
division would be the sentimental
favorite and
and it just would feel good but if we
want a compelling playoff game
the following weekend giants hosting the
bucks
is the best combination so go giants
chris
great i'll be pulling for your giants on
sunday yeah go big boo
here we go yeah i agree i mean i i think
that would be the most compelling
matchup
i'm with you you know hopefully daniel
jones could be healthy this weekend in
that wild card football game
but yeah i think they match up pretty
good with the tampa football team and
yes because of patrick graham the
defensive staff there
hey those coaches you know you know we
heard those reports a few weeks ago
about some of the comments that
that were made behind the scenes about
brady you know
and all those type of things it all adds
a little intrigue
uh to the matchup if it does happen but
you know either way
i think brady on the road in tan you
know on the tampa bay football team is
going to be a pretty good watch no
matter who it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports